in the room so did you want to do
something oh yeah
um so different shift
um obviously women earn their own money
and they earn good money nowadays right
so women have almost in certain ways
adopted the traditional masculine
positions that men have taken
historically
but then a lot of women will still say
that they don't want to provide for a
man so it's almost like they've taken
the position of a man but they don't
want to take the responsibility that
comes with that position I just want to
know why do you guys think that is or do
you think that's even a fair statement
to say
um I
no I think it's just again just like
subjective you know
um I've been in a position where I
supported my man for like two years
would you have been happy to do that if
you stayed together like for the
duration of your relationship
yeah if I had to for sure but like I
think again
there is that Natural Energy exchange
that needs to take place
um obviously like I would probably have
that conversation but like hey you know
but like why but what I'm trying to say
is like if you're the person in the
relationship who is earning more right
why would you have to be like okay we
need to have a conversation about this
why could you just be like okay well I'm
just going to be providing for the
relationship because I feel like there's
like an energy of like resentment that
might come up and where and I guess what
I'm asking is where does that come from
because I agree yeah um honestly I don't
know
um would you say it's entitlement
no did you still find that man
attractive yes yeah yeah
I think a woman can do it if she thinks
it's temporary yes yeah and the thing is
like we were we were building like
together so I was involved in the dream
he was involved in the dream and we were
building his dream you know and so I
supported that 100 so I could also gone
so I could never be the provider of my
of my home never I don't want to I think
it's confusing for the children it's
confusing for me yeah
I like it's not my role I always have
like why is he not working is it is he
staying home and it's not that he's not
working right but it's like let's say
for example your chosen career paths
right you're earning 8K he's earning 30k
right and you want to live a certain
lifestyle but in order to live that
lifestyle like you have to be uh uh have
the financial burden of let's say 90 of
the relationship
then that's fine because you want that
lifestyle right like the woman wants the
life but you would be okay you'd like
you'd be okay providing for him yeah if
the woman wants the lifestyle then
you're gonna have to the woman's gonna
have to uphold it otherwise she would
have to come down a level but she has to
uphold it for herself and for him yeah
so you know the way men have
traditionally brought women up to their
lifestyle you're doing the same for your
man like but I feel like most women
would not want to do that like you said
like a lot of time if a woman's here
she's like I want a guy who's here or
above hashtag hypergamy
you know what um Auntie said she said
that um last time she was on the show I
don't know if you you guys probably I
don't know if you've seen Clips with her
she's like this um 50 something year old
Auntie that's just like yeah she's so
funny and she said that
um I I knew a couple that like where he
worked and she worked and she would just
come home and give the money to her
husband all these women say that they
can't trust the man with the money but
they trust them with their bodies and my
body's a lot more valuable than some
money
that's true but I can I can um if me and
my husband are working I'm happy to put
my money in a joint account for her to
give it to him though I don't think the
kind of man I'll be with would want it
to be seen like that he would probably
just I think in my head I could be wrong
but I just I wouldn't mind in my home is
we sit down we plan and he says you are
only allowed to spend this amount of
your money you have to put the rest in
savings I'm okay with that so you you
don't mind being the constant because
essentially even though you're putting
into one pot you're the breadwinner no
no no no we're saying that we're talking
about how we manage our money so he he
he I was I won't use the word control
you know that's when we don't like
saying words but I wouldn't use the
words control I'll say but he has a
final say on how I spend I'm okay with
that if he says with you earning more
no even if he was earning more no this
is
I'm just making a comment what she said
managing money
so so you like let's say you earn 100K I
don't know what you're gonna let's just
say you're in 100K he makes 55.
he's a hard-working man he's a fireman I
wouldn't be with someone who's a fireman
though
why shout out to the firemen but
why not like that that could be like a
masculine guy it's a good job no no no
no no see
let's even leave the money side of
things I I don't want to be thinking I
hope he's okay where he is oh okay I
can't deal with it
I've been a police officer all of that I
I you know I respect women let's say
plumber okay let's let's change it to
plumber it wasn't about they make money
anyway so no 55. you know you know what
I'm I'm a mum so we do have to make
certain like the truth of the matter is
we have to
compromise a little bit I could be with
a plumber who's on 50K if he had a plan
to not always be on that 50k but it's
hard no this isn't build a bomb the same
building I was just about to say I was
just about to say that hard
we date potential yeah yeah and hope
yeah so it's like yeah but so the answer
there's no no no no yeah I don't think
that's a mistake I have a problem with
this though because a lot of women seem
to do this quite a lot because every
woman wants a man to to be rich and
successful no I don't know okay because
I said he least have a plan okay sorry
sorry so I know I'm interrupting you
sorry but I think it's based on your age
if I'm dating a guy who's like if I
decide to date younger I cannot expect
him to be on certain salaries but if I'm
dating a guy and I think I prefer to
date guys who are like 35 and up I
should be seeing your progression by now
you shouldn't be I would or could or
Shoulda yeah but if I date the other end
of the age group then I can't expect you
to have it all together I think 50k is
still tough for some people still no but
I'm saying my point is for some 50 right
but I'm saying like like 50k is still I
couldn't find it exactly but like 20 30
of income or do you think your your top
20 30 of women yeah what financially no
okay so what man values unless that one
serve except in my fate but what one
thing is I I know my I know my personal
I know my trades and I think as a woman
you have to know your behavior I don't
think that's a problem I think and then
this is why I pulled it up because a lot
of women seem to have this I don't want
to find a guy's potential whatever
whatever the age if a guy's making
around 55k we know the statistics around
what percentage of men make that money
yeah how unrealistic is most women's
perspective on okay so I I agree that
some women think they should have
certain things because they see other
women having it but you don't know what
those women are doing to get what they
what what they have I.E either they're
working hard or the things they accept
in their home you can't even accept one
percent of it so unless unless you have
full knowledge on people's situations
don't ask for what you don't know also a
minute making 50 bags well the moment I
know they are no no okay okay
but that's why I say that for me I can't
be with a guy who's on 50K because I
know my traits I know my behavior and
unfortunately I will start to resent him
and I won't be happy as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible